this video is brought to you by morning
brew the daily email newsletter covering
the latest news from Wall Street to
Silicon Valley more info on morning brew
at the end of this video what's up guys
Helen here if you ask anyone to explain
why they love Nathan for you they'll
probably say some iteration of you just
have to watch it Nathan fielder paints a
bizarre picture of America colored by
strange individuals ranging from the
verbally abusive private investigator
you might be the Wizard of loneliness to
the ex-con Santa Claus to these stalker
esque Bill Gates impersonator on one
level nathan is impossibly complex and
nonsensical plans belie analysis but as
you already know that's not gonna stop
us because Pablo all the insanity the
show crackles with brilliant commentary
holding up a mirror to the absurdity of
running a modern business welcome to
this wisecrack edition on Nathan for you
and sorta maybe kind of spoilers ahead
here's the premise of the show and your
typical episode of Nathan for you
host Nathan fielder introduces us to one
or more struggling business owners and
proposes a cockamamie plan to improve
their luck do let miners purchase
alcohol but then held it in a storage
locker until their 21st birthday bouquet
Plaza liquor would gain a ton of new
underage customers then we watch the
plan escalate deviate and almost
inevitably fail through this mashup of
retail and history it is a train wreck
on the most basic level many of the
plots Nathan concoct reveals something
about the strange relationship between
morality and economic realities she's
seriously are talking about putting a
banner that says we sell liquor to
minors nathan has described the way the
series was born partially out of his own
obsession with the 2008 economic
collapse in which risky bank behavior
took down the global economy what really
fascinated him was the way this
cataclysmic fiscal wrap was the result
of thousands in
some seemingly mundane moments like when
one guy must have known his boss's
credit default swap magic was a bunch of
boo-boo in nearly every episode of
Nathan for you
he makes us live through these kinds of
sickening moments after he's pitched an
absurd and sometimes immoral idea to a
business owner the plan turned the job
of moving into America's next fitness
craze watch each person reluctantly
agreed to ideas that will likely mislead
exploit the labor of insult or terrify
customers I think you'll get a lot more
people if they just think it's a workout
and we don't tell them that they're
actually doing free labor
there's the antique store owner who
tepidly extends her business hours to
learn and drunk customers who are gonna
fall prey to the stores you break it you
buy it policy
I just wouldn't prefer a broken item I'd
rather sell a good one but yeah I mean
it would be the same thing no matter
what happens so during each of these
moments the owners reluctance is
palpable but it's typically eclipsed by
their desire to improve their business
mm-hmm to please Nathan probably yes
yeah we'll think that oh yeah or simply
just say on TV you know I want to see
what how it works I would love to have
this information and then if I have the
use yes why not using it typically it'll
justify it as a means of achieving
bottom line profits
any product it's always beneficial to
those stores in this subset of Nathan's
pranks watching decent human beings
cajoled into small acts of immorality
ranges from painfully uncomfortable to
flat-out unbelievable okay you know the
drill right blast-off
take the time Nathan convinces this man
that he's being hired as a shell PR
representative enticed by the incentive
of a good job
the man is willing to say things like
this this mill right here this bill was
like relatively small if you had to have
a spill somewhere you would want this
bill
Nathan highlights the way a system that
emphasizes personal gains at the expense
of community good sets up decent human
beings to become their worst selves and
these are for people that you cut in
front of that you thought you were
better than including a nine-year-old
girl part of the strength of Nathan's
satire comes from the fact that each of
his ideas have some real-world basis he
takes business antics that were
generally pretty comfortable with and
transports them to a place of wheezy
moral incongruity for example in the
TWiT company episode he takes up
familiar kind of advertising and targets
a tour children owning a doink it is now
the only proof that you are not a baby
here Nathan reveals something
uncomfortable about businesses that
stealthily exploit or worst insecurities
to get a piece of our hard-earned
paycheck Nathan for you showcases the
struggle of the small business owner
trying to compete in the global economy
subverting the narrative that anyone
willing to work hard can simply pull
themselves up by their own bootstraps
Nathan puts his own spin on the American
Dream by first giving us the classic
protagonist a hard-working cab driver or
electronics store owner it's horrible I
mean it's it's it's it's bad for a small
business then he paints his own presence
as the savvy business consultant or the
dose of luck they need to revitalize
their business but maybe there's a
shortcut to actually having brand
recognition using a little something
called parody law isn't actually to help
the businesses find success it's to
underscore the absurdity superficiality
and futility of modern-day business in
the first place for instance even when
his scheme to make an elaborately
orchestrated video of a pig rescuing a
goat in a petting zoo go viral actually
worked
he perversely left the zoo's name
out of the video I didn't wanted to come
across like an ad you know for the
petting zoo I thought it would be a bit
transparent so but if people would have
known that it was oak tree village this
mistake is a gag that actually gets to
the heart of the show's mission the
short lifespan of any viral animal video
pretty much ensures the fact that even
if properly advertised the petting zoo
would have quickly faded back into
cultural oblivion
Nathan just expedited the process even
when Nathan's plans do succeed in the
short term they're typically too
implausible to survive in a long term
Los Angeles Health Department shut down
dumb Starbucks yesterday because it did
not have proper permits usually the
business owner ends up exactly where
they started and just maybe the show is
highlighting the impossibility of going
up against big business even when your
plans are insane and involve alligators
this is never more clear than when
Nathan attempts to take on global brands
in one episode he tries to help an
electronic store owner compete with Best
Buy their sales are ridiculous I mean
there's no way that I can compete part
of the problem is Best Buy's price-match
policy in which they promised to match
any price from neighboring stores
preventing anyone from underselling them
Nathan proposes they use price match
against the company by offering to sell
TVs for $1 which would allow them to
stock up on Best Buy's entire supply as
expected
Best Buy finds way out of it
why not of course at the same time the
Nathan is trying to use BestBuy system
to his advantage he and the small store
owner are going to even more elaborate
and absurd lengths to game their own
customers printing out some flyers and
distributing them throughout the
neighborhood it was finally time for
Allen to offer his $1 prices to the
world obscuring their $1 TVs with a
black tie dress code and a live
alligator after a failed ball suit and a
staged reality show we ultimately hear
the message loud and clear the
international corporations can design
rules that plunge small businesses into
financial ruin I'm just so sick and
tired of these big companies like Best
Buy and Enron thinking that you know the
rules don't apply to them not content to
suggest that the hyper competitive
business climate robs us of our morality
and doomed us all to failure the show
also explores the uncomfortable
relationship between modern business
objectives and mortality to understand
why this matters we have to examine the
ideas of Pulitzer prize-winning social
theorist Ernest Becker who saw the
motivations behind our desire to acquire
money as simply put our futile efforts
to escape death as he wrote in his book
escape from evil money can be
accumulated and passed on and so
radiates its powers even after ones
death giving one a semblance of
immortality nathan explores this
relationship in several of his episodes
taking the logic of acquisition and the
narcissism implicit in it and applies it
to the most morbid of possible causes of
funeral industry in one episode he
convinces a funeral home to offer a
service in which the unpopular lead EDD
can hire actors to attend their funerals
so that they appear to be well-liked
this is the ridiculous
albian logical extension of a
consumerist world in which we amassed
objects and Instagram likes in order to
feel hip cool and
but there's more in other episodes
Nathan explores the uncomfortable
aspects of monetizing death he convinces
a travel agent who only has very elderly
customers to start offering funeral
services to squeeze those customers for
every cent before they quit he takes a
very familiar logic diapers to find your
business and makes it incredibly eerie
by literally capitalizing off death's
this is a last-ditch effort to squeeze
out as much as you can from your
customers before they're gone for good
by applying a pretty banal business
concept to the most ghoulish of
circumstances
Nathan exposes the inherit vulture ISM
sometimes implicit in trying to upsell
your customers towards the end
Nathan attempts to save on the overhead
cost of cremations by testing out the
idea of using ink wood fire pizza oven
instead of a crematorium a few more
hours would it all just burn to a crisp
yeah would that work the same for a
human body at the same time there's
actually a really strange hopefulness
and sincerity to Nathan for you think
about it this is one of the very few
reality shows in which the people
depicted typically don't come across as
crazed narcissistic jerks they're
actually for the most part pretty
sympathetic the show will often stall on
strange moments of humanity even if it's
somewhat disturbing like the gas station
owners propensity for drinking his
grandsons urine I am promoting because
grandsons pee sometimes how are these
sexually experimental brothers so you
guys are brothers mm-hmm
and you guys you'll have sex with the
same girl or the extremely ghosts where
a realtor yeah why earlier my wife by an
entity other times these displays of
humanity are just really genuine gonna
be okay it's gonna be okay the show
highlights the tension between those
slivers of humanity and the mandates of
our modern economy for instance in one
scheme
Nathan sets his production assistant
Solomon up on a date but agrees to have
it sponsored by Quiznos
so a Quiznos rep is brought on standby
to deliver branded dialogue in real time
for Solomon to say I'm sayin toasty
toasty this is a very self reflexive
critique of the television industry as a
whole which at the end of the day only
makes money by patting it's gripping
human dramas and comedies with
commercial breaks every ten or so
minutes furthermore if the show asks in
a world oversaturated with advertising
how can we hope for a true connection
the show's best through-line explores
this question by depicting Nathan's
ongoing quest to find love and
friendship
whether Nathan's forcing and auditioning
actress to say I love you I love you
again I love you or asking a shopkeeper
if he'd like to hang out rejected would
you ever want to hang out sometimes
socially with me outside of this you
know Nathan's antics are hilarious
because they're perfectly calibrated to
turn people off he's the king of
inopportune hugs and misguided attempts
at small talk if it makes it a little
bit safer would you be comfortable just
being handcuffed Nathan enjoys letting
his genuine vulnerabilities take center
stage this is never more true than when
Nathan treats himself like a struggling
business I know that as a TV host having
a personality that people don't like is
bad for business and that's why I needed
to make a change scheming to improve his
desirability as a friend and lover he
paints himself as the hunk on a made-up
dating show
he also conducts a focus group to
improve his likeability I think the
v-neck would go well with him a v-neck
really and sage is an elaborate
scientific experiment to improve that
hanging out with him is fun so if
there's serotonin or dopamine levels go
up when they're hanging out with me that
would mean that I'm fun
in trading human interaction like a
business Nathan embodies the loneliness
and isolation of our modern world
at other times Nathan actually offers an
answer with strange moments of genuine
human connectedness throughout the
series solidarity forms amongst a troupe
of rebate seekers who camp out with
Nathan on the mountain we agree with you
the friendship that we gained here is
just incredible
so let's go down the mountain and an
oddly compelling relationship develops
between Nathan and TVs most lovable sex
worker may see these interactions are
always mediated by money on some level
the rebate seekers are waiting for
Nathan to get them their rebates and
macey is being paid handsomely to hang
out with him but glimmers of true
curiosity affection and shared humanity
shine through and it's really beautiful
to watch it suggests that human
connectedness is the bomb that can make
the current conditions of the modern
world bearable sometimes Nathan
literalizes this thesis by sending the
subjects of his failed schemes upon
dates
suggesting that their economic
situations could be bearable if only
they had love in conclusion Nathan for
you is a giant smirk holding a sign that
says please love me it explores all the
cynical motivations that govern us in
this ruthless era of startups and
branded everything and hey at the end of
the day maybe hanging out with the right
group of weirdos could be just the
antidote you need thanks for watching
everyone peace but since we all have to
have a job you're gonna want to stay
informed about the world of business
rather than getting bogged down by all
those Ed's business new sites consider
cutting through the clutter with morning
brew I used to work for a Business
Journal so I've seen firsthand just how
inaccessible
sites can be warning brew is a free
daily newsletter that keeps you informed
delivering the latest business stories
right here in box all in a punchy
informative easy-to-understand email and
you could subscribe for free in just 10
seconds at morning brew calm or use the
link in description I'd already heard
lots of great stuff about wearing brew
and since I'm practically obsessed with
following the shenanigans a big business
I decided to give it a whirl and I've
loved it now every day I wake up to
moves on brexit what's going on with my
shrimp and Bitcoin balance the latest
outrage over Elon Musk
even though personally kind of a total
fangirl and tons more so if you're
looking to quickly sharpen your
knowledge on everything from Wall Street
to Silicon Valley make morning brew a
new part of your routine sign up for
free by clicking the link in description
we're going to morning brew calm thanks
for watching and catch you guys next
time